the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think about that kid Edmund Shabazz Ian
I saw his fight I didn't know who he was
till um it was Tim I'm saying his last
name right right yeah yeah till um
what's his name um Tim told me like oh
[ __ ] then I rewatched the fightingest
what is he alive I can't remember
dude he's 21 any hope brides of ours
with a head kick and I kind of got my
attention like what [ __ ] who's this kid
he starched him with that right hand and
you know that's what I mean like he's at
185 he's 21
yeah he's on the come up just beat I
played with Brad for five rounds he
starts him in one round you know I'm not
taking that likely yeah I look at that
kid eventually when it when he comes up
you know I'm sure I'll see him at some
point but that's what I mean I need to
get back to work don't get me wrong I
understand working yeah I'm worse man
but like I want to you know you know
there's no more oh yeah well that he is
well if I don't train that is the thing
of pressure that is the thing of
pressure of being a champion you know
I'll never forget when BJ Penn choked
out Matt Hughes to win the title in 170
and I was interviewing Matt in the in
the Octagon he was real honest about it
was I'm gonna be honest with you this is
a relief it was the pressure the
pressure of all these guys coming after
me for so long he was I'm glad it's off
my show they're not used to it and
that's why I said that about Robert um I
said on record like I said he's not used
to this pressures and the quiet tastes
it's an acquired taste not everyone
likes it it's like caviar a Gucci or yes
some ask exactly people don't understand
it and for me before the UFC there's a
hike you know I jump in the UFC do my
work hype hype hype all the way through
yeah and I said I've been chopping this
pressure for breakfast lunch and dinner
it's easy to me the guy's been away the
whole time I've been running through the
[ __ ] division the time I've been
clean you know like staking my claim as
a [ __ ] champ and he's not used to
this pressure and you'll come back fight
you want to come up in the biggest show
against me hmm I wouldn't even if I was
a coach
16 months is too long to put a guy
against me and I said he's not gonna be
used to and he said oh you know I don't
care you know this is it I fellas not as
good as he thinks he is
all right watch this
well the thing about the UFC is you
don't get to know fights now they don't
exist that's why I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna come here ready because I know
they're gonna put me in the deep end
you're gonna put me against the guy so
that's why I mean usually had the plan
like we got to be ready for everyone
yeah to be honest I'm glad it happened
the way it happened I'm glad I didn't
rush and people were like oh my goodness
Tripp you have history I didn't want to
because if I not like I'm glad all this
[ __ ] happened to me no when I was 23 or
24 cuz I would have [ __ ] up don't
weigh worth [ __ ] you know but I'm happy
that I matured I had my metamorphosis
when I was 28 and that's when a shift
happened for me
that's when I became trying to help a
lot as well like being away from my
comfort zone being in the mainland and
hey man like trying to help me get ready
for this cuz being a big black man in
the mainland they don't really see
people like us all the time fighting in
my first Stadium show in China in front
of 40,000 people being mobbed in China
all that stuff I just uses his rep so I
was like okay this is all preparing me
for this this is all preparing me for
the big time so when this time comes I
got to be ready and I got to roll out do
you have a very wise way of looking at
the future and I think that's what led
you to getting therapy when you started
feeling a little weird after your first
fight I mean that's a very intelligent
to seek help to try to figure out okay
there's got to be a good way to handle
this and I need tools yeah there's a
stigma around it as well even when I
mentioned I think I put it up put my um
on my Instagram story after um my wooden
against Robert Whittaker I went to a
therapist that Monday the session was
supposed to last maybe an hour and a
half we finished in 30 minutes because I
saw her two weeks beforehand the week of
the fight and then I saw her after the
fight and literally was like cool I
think we got what we needed all right
I'll see you if I need you again but
then people were like all so brave you
know you come out and you know if people
with mental illness and oh my god
hashtag am i I'm not a is it not
everyone is mentally ill but everyone
has to look after the mental health yeah
and you will get sick physical health if
I start eating [ __ ] drinking all day
I'll get physically sick so if you don't
look after your mental health then
you're going
get men to the hill uh Emily gonna put
you in a straitjacket yes and all that
you know yeah you don't want that so for
me I just have to look after myself I
don't want to end up like 2007 Brittany
you know though I think she looked all
right that's that's where you dealing
with the young person and when you said
about that you're not the youngest-ever
champ I don't think it's good I don't
think it's good to have that kind of
unqualified success at an unqualified
you don't deserve it but yeah
unprecedented Tyson
like Mike Tyson you talk openly about it
man I mean now you hung out with Mike I
was supposed to this week but he's busy
so another time
well a little more to it dude was do the
hot box together he's a nice guy man and
he's he's so philosophical about his
past and the way he's very garbage yeah
garbage yeah he doesn't like to even
think about who he doesn't like to work
out yeah because he doesn't want to
bring that ego back they see him
LaFrentz isn't gonna when he's but he
apparently he's gonna train Francis they
said yeah that would be interested
really Gypsy Kings that I do have it may
I'd love to see it man Viki actually
like once he gets that first leg kick
[ __ ] have I done but now you better get
it before you get in the cage I'll say
that
[Applause]